[Music]
the good news is that your experimental
Robo ants are a success the bad news is
that you accidentally just gave them the
ability to shoot deadly lasers and you
can't turn it off you have five minutes
to stop them before the lasers go online
until then all of your robo ants will
walk inside their habitat at a speed of
exactly 1 meter per minute if they bump
into each other or hit a dead end
they'll instantly turn around and walk
back the way they came when 5 minutes
are up they'll turn on their lasers
break free and stream out into the world
carving a path of destruction as they go
your one chance to stop them is to
insert the two emergency vacuum nozzles
into the habitat and suck the ants up
before they break free the nozzles can
press into any one location in the
habitat through a membrane covering its
front side and any ants that walk past
will be sucked up and deactivated you
can't move the nozzles once they're
placed without leaving a hole that the
Robo ants would pour out of so choosing
the right spots will be key the habitat
is made out of metre long tubes when the
robots reach an intersection they will
pick randomly whether to go left right
or forward they only go backward if they
hit another Robo ant or a dead end
unfortunately there are hundreds of them
inside the habitat and if even one
escapes it'll do a lot of damage with
just less than five minutes remaining
where should you place the to vacuum
nozzles to suck up all the Robo ants
with robo ants ricocheting all over the
habitat it might seem impossible to stop
them before they break free but this
situation is simpler than it seems
here's why imagine just two Robo ants
crawling toward each other when they
collide they immediately reverse
directions and what would that sequence
of events look like if they crawled past
each other instead it would look exactly
the same before and after their
collision but with their positions
swapped this is true every time a pair
of Robo ants meet because the identities
of individual ants don't matter you just
need to figure out where you should put
the nozzles to capture any single ant
walking without interruption for less
than five minutes starting from any
point in the habitat that's much easier
to conceptualize and solve placing the
nozzles at intersections where three or
four tubes meet seems like your best bet
since that's where the robo ants might
otherwise change directions and miss
your nozzles there are only four
intersections which two should you pick
the top right intersection has to be one
of them if it isn't an ant crawling down
from this intersection toward the dead
end would crawl for four minutes to get
back to the intersection and then go in
any of three directions walking for at
least another minute once you've placed
a nozzle in the top right the only other
choice that has a chance to work is the
bottom left to see that this works
imagine an ant anywhere else in the
habitat worst case scenario the ant
would start right next to the vacuum
nozzle marching away from it but in all
those worst cases the ant would March
for at most four meters before being
sucked up into the vacuum no other
choice of two intersection points is
guaranteed to get all the Robo ants
within five minutes
having vacuumed them all up you've
averted a major crisis before you mess
with a robo ants again you'll want to
have a robo anteater ready and wouldn't
it be cool if it could fly and breathe
fire there's no way that could go wrong
for today's bonus riddle suppose you
have a single tube with 30 Robo ants on
and twenty robo ants on the other all
the ants in each side start out marching
in a line and at a uniform pace towards
the other end of the tube when two ants
bump into each other they instantly turn
around and walk back the way they came
how many total ant collisions will there
be this bonus riddle comes courtesy of
our sponsor brilliant brilliant helps
you develop your joy of learning by
cultivating your curiosity applying what
you learn and allowing for failure try
them out at brilliant org slash ted-ed
and the first eight hundred thirty three
of you to use that link will get a
twenty percent discount off the annual
subscription and finally you can find a
link to the solution to brilliance bonus
Robo ants riddle in the description
below